[APPLAUSE]
ROB LEONARD: Hello again.
TONY TRAGUARDO:
Hello again, Mark.
MITCH AXELROD: We
had the pleasure
of speaking with Mark
this morning for our show.
And again, we want to
start at the beginning.
Why did you feel it
necessary to write
another book about the Beatles
and the history of the Beatles?
So many have been written.
MARK LEWISOHN: Well,
there are so many books.
I don't know how
many people here
have Beatle books on their
shelves, but I have about 500
at home.
And myself I've done a
half a dozen in the past.
But they were all
reference books.
Most of the Beatles books are
a niche area of the subject.
And they look at it.
And they go quite deep on it.
But they're quite
specialists in that way.
In terms of biography,
there are still very few.
And I didn't feel that any
single biography had ever
really covered the
Beatles in the way
that I wanted to read
about it and in the way
that I think their story
demands and deserves.
So I just decided
that I would do it.
But I would do it
with a difference
in that I would write about
it in deeply in three volumes.
Because if you try
and cram this story,
in all its many
ramifications, into one book,
then you are going
to have to leave out
a lot of material
that's absolutely
necessary to the understanding.
So the idea came up for
this three-volume series.
And I was able to get
a publisher the UK
and here in the US.
Thank you to my team who
are here today, brilliantly.
And they've been really patient
because it took a while.
But the idea is that this
story, in my opinion,
has never really been
told properly before.
And the idea is to press the
refresh button on something
that we think we
know, and to actually
look at it again from
the top to the bottom,
from the side to the side, every
which way, and do it properly.
MITCH AXELROD: Now
we are at Google.
So obviously we want to talk
a little bit about research
because a long time ago,
when people did their books,
it was libraries and phone
disks and no internet.
You've had the good fortune
of having the internet.
But you've also done the
old-fashioned way as well.
Why don't you talk a little
bit about the research you did.
MARK LEWISOHN: Well, I
figure that if you only
research your book on the
internet, then by definition
you're not going to be
able to get anything that
is special and unique to you
because it will be something
that has been found before,
has been typed by someone,
and is up there because
someone's put it up there.
So obviously, the internet
is a phenomenal resource.
And we will use it.
And it was a great help to me
on this project in every way.
But at the same
time, you can't be
doing old-fashioned
detective work
and getting out there
and burning shoe leather.
And I burned shoe leather
and car tires and whatever.
I needed to go wherever
the information was.
And this story is now
quite an old story.
I mean the book begins
in the 19th century.
But even when the
book really begins
to accelerate after they're
born-- the Beatles are all war
babies, which is quite
important to the story--
when you're looking
at 1940s and '50s
and '60s resource
materials, a lot of that
is still not available
on the internet.
You have to go to the libraries.
You have to go
into the archives.
And you have to do
proper research.
So it's a combination.
I always say with this book,
I go where the information is.
If it's easily available,
I'll grab it easily.
If it's difficult to obtain,
I'll go that extra mile.
MITCH AXELROD: So where
was the information?
MARK LEWISOHN:
The information is
in personal and private hands.
It's in public
archives and libraries.
It's in corporate archives.
It's in old newspapers
and magazines and books
and radio and
television and film.
It's wherever you need to go
and whatever you need to do.
So a lot of time in the
Liverpool record office, which
is looking at birth
records and school
records in Liverpool, England.
A lot of the time in
the archives of the BBC
or the archives of their
record company, EMI.
None of that stuff's
been digitized
so you have to go to it.
And in particular,
archives of people
who had an
association with them,
like lawyers who might have kept
legal files or broadcasters who
kept files, all
that kind of stuff.
TONY TRAGUARDO:
Now Mark, there's
been so much written
about the music.
You've started way back
with literally the birth
of each of the individual
members of the group.
But when it comes to
going back to Liverpool,
you're relying on
people's memories.
You're relying on a
combination of information
that's been available
and, as you say,
newly discovered information.
You found some conflict, of
course, amongst all of this.
So how did you work through all
of the many, many conflicting
stories about the Beatles?
MARK LEWISOHN: Well,
the Beatles is often
the biggest thing
that ever happened
to someone in their life.
If they had an association
with the Beatles,
you can imagine it is
something that they talk about
forevermore-- most
people, not all.
And inevitably along
the way, their stories
begin to gather layers
that weren't actually
necessarily there
in the first place.
So one of the things that
I can bring to the project
like this is I have a wealth
of background knowledge.
I've been doing this now for
30-odd years professionally.
So you have to know when people
are talking bull, basically.
And I have a very
strong sense of that.
No matter how exciting the
story, if someone's telling me
something that I know will
look good on the page,
but I don't quite believe
it, I won't use it
because accuracy is absolutely
everything to a book like this.
There's no point in doing this
again unless it's accurate.
MITCH AXELROD: What
about the George Harrison
quote that is in the book?
MARK LEWISOHN: There's a quote
in the book where George says,
in their bid to
tell what they know,
some people tell more
than what they know.
And that is the same thing.
Stories become
embroidered with time.
In an interview even where I'm
really comfortable with what
someone's telling
me as the truth,
there'll still be
something that I won't use.
And there are some people
I won't go to at all
because I know what
they're going to say.
And I know it's unusable.
TONY TRAGUARDO: The script.
They have a script.
MARK LEWISOHN:
Yeah, it's a script.
And some people actually
have made a living out
of putting themselves
more centrally
into a picture they were
never in in the first place.
ROB LEONARD: Mark, you've been
doing research on the Beatles
for, like you said,
over 30 years.
When you were doing
interviews along the way,
were you thinking about
this book at this point?
Because you obviously have a
great archive of interviews
with the Beatles themselves.
MARK LEWISOHN: No,
I didn't know I
was going to be doing this until
pretty much when I started it.
So all the times in the past
I've had access to people,
I could have asked them
certain things and didn't.
But you know, I didn't
have that foresight.
But this is very much
a book of information.
And with Beatle collectors,
I am a Beatle fan,
but at the same time, I'm
an independent professional
historian.
So I have the
enthusiasm of a fan
to carry me through a
long project like this,
but I'm not interested in
polishing their reputation
in any way.
So this is not a book saying,
hey, weren't the Beatles great?
This is an independent history.
And it doesn't pull any punches.
But it's essentially
a book of information.
And Beatle fans collect
different things.
And I, more than anything
else, collect information.
And I've had incredible
access to archives
through working for the
Beatles for so long.
I've been in many
good situations
where I've had
access to archives.
And I always take
the moment if I can,
if there's an opportunity.
So I have filing cabinets
full of history, basically,
and that's all going to
go into these three books.
TONY TRAGUARDO: But
we could add, though,
that while the book
is information,
there's quite a bit of humor.
And that is really wonderful.
There's a great
humorous aspect partly
because, as we've talked about,
the Beatles themselves were--
MARK LEWISOHN: Well,
yeah, absolutely.
I mean, they're just
such funny guys.
And their story
always makes me laugh.
I still laugh hysterically at
most aspects of the Beatles.
And it's really important
that a book like this
should have humor in it.
And I'm glad that
you noticed that.
ROB LEONARD: How
important is the fact
that they're from Liverpool and
not London or someplace else?
MARK LEWISOHN: It's crucial.
It's crucial.
We live in a world now where
rock music is everywhere.
You can't avoid it.
Even when you want to avoid
it, you can't avoid it.
And this is a
contextual history.
So I'm writing about
the 1950s and '60s
when rock music was the
music of delinquents.
And it was greatly frowned
upon in mainstream society.
Adults did not get it.
It was not their music.
They thought it was
associated with hoodlums.
And therefore they shunned it.
And what was the question?
ROB LEONARD: How
important was the fact
that the Beatles
were from Liverpool?
MARK LEWISOHN: Yeah, so we
live in a world now full
of rock music.
And rock bands are everywhere.
In those days, in the
late '50s, early '60s,
there was no real rock band
scene anywhere in America.
There had been
some rock and roll
and corporate America was trying
to suppress it, to kill it off,
with the payola scandal and
all of that of the late 1950s.
And it really survived
primarily in England
where everybody in England,
all the kids in England
growing up who loved
American music,
they didn't want
anything from England.
It had to be American.
And in England there was
really only one place
where there was a scene, where
there were bands forming, mates
playing guitars, swapping
chords, swapping songs, getting
up on stage and singing.
It wasn't London.
It was Liverpool.
It was the only
place in the world,
in other words, that
had a rock band scene.
And the Beatles,
initially, they weren't
in the first wave of that.
They were not there at
its formative period.
They joined it
after two or three
years it had been
up and running.
And when they got back from
Germany the first time,
which is another story,
they took it over.
And they were the kings
very, very quickly.
And they were different
from everybody else
because they were original.
The Beatles always
broke all the rules.
They were always original.
They were never tied
by any convention.
They thought differently.
They look different.
They acted different.
And they were the kings.
ROB LEONARD: And they also
played different songs
from the other bands
because they would often
look at a B-side,
let's say, which
is something you don't
think about because you'd
want to play the A-side
because everyone knew it.
MARK LEWISOHN: Yeah,
I mean, the Beatles
didn't have iPlayers--
sorry-- didn't
have iPads or iPods
or anything like that.
They were in record
shop listening booths,
browseries they were called.
And they would all
squeeze themselves in
and they would ask the
assistant behind the counter
to play this one, this
one, this one, this one.
And whatever they picked
that was from America.
They only wanted to
play American music.
And they would be crowded
into these browseries.
And one of them
very quickly would
say something was
crap, usually John.
And they would take it off, and
they would put on the next one.
And someone, Paul, would
say, I'll do this one.
Or John would say,
I'll do this one.
Or George would say,
And that's how they
got a repertoire.
But they looked for the unusual.
So they went to the B-sides.
And they went for the
really obscure tracks
that no one else
was even playing.
And they popularized a lot
of American music that way
that wasn't even popular here.
MITCH AXELROD:
And actually, they
made African American music
accessible here to white people
in America, which was a
very big thing for them.
They were very proud of
it because they were not
into the segregation.
Correct?
MARK LEWISOHN: The
Beatles was first album
is principally a New York sound.
It's the music of 1650 Broadway
properly known as the Brill
Building, but actually
that was across the street.
It's the music of Jerry
Goffin and Carole King
and songwriters like that,
Burt Bacharach and Hal David.
And that was the first album.
The second album was
really a Detroit sound.
They were looking for the Motown
sound, the Tamla Motown sound.
And then they
exploded in America
and were able to get back
to you the music that
was yours in the
first place, but often
hadn't been heard before.
TONY TRAGUARDO: And
they actually brought
that music out of
just the club scene
by being the first to perform
a Tamla Motown track on the BBC
radio.
MARK LEWISOHN: Yeah,
that was interesting.
The Beatles first
appeared on the radio
in England in a session
before they actually
had a recording contract.
And one of the songs they
played in their first forecast
was "Please, Mr. Postman"
by the Marvelettes on Tamla.
And I thought, I wonder how many
times that record or anything
else from Tamla had been
played on British radio before?
So again, this is
nothing digitized here.
I spent days going
through microfilm records,
wearing out my eyes, turning
film round and round and round
on all the BBC program
output records.
So every record played in every
radio show would be logged.
And I went through the logs.
And it turned out
my hunch was right.
They were the first
to play a Tamla
sound from Detroit on BBC Radio.
And then in their
next broadcast,
they played a song
"Ask Me Why" that
was based on a Tamla record,
or inspired by a Tamla record.
So that was also a first.
They, I'm sure, didn't
know any of this.
They were just doing it.
It's down to the historian
to come along and put it
into context.
But they were doing it.
They were the first.
MITCH AXELROD: Let's go back
in the past just a little bit.
We've gone to the music.
And we'll get back to
that because we really
need to find out how the
Beatles did get their music.
You had mentioned
it a little bit.
But let's go back
to the childhood.
Because again, you say the
book is a social history
with the Beatles at
the center of it.
So let's talk about each Beatle,
briefly, about their childhood
and musically what
they had and such.
MARK LEWISOHN: OK,
so starting with?
MITCH AXELROD: That
boy, John Lennon.
MARK LEWISOHN: OK.
John, Paul, and George,
all the products
of Catholic
Protestant marriages,
which is an unusual
mix in Liverpool which
had a particularly
strong religious divide.
You would normally stick
to your own religion.
Most unusual that
three of the Beatles
actually have that mixed
background, which, I think,
it is part of their makeup.
I'm not quite sure what it says,
but it's part of who they are.
John Lennon was born
in 1940 when Liverpool
was being bombed by the Germans.
Liverpool was very, very
badly bombed by the Nazis
in the Second World War.
He wasn't born in an air raid.
But all the same,
there were bombs
falling very close by
within a day or two
of where he was born.
And he was born to a father
who was a merchant seamen who
was actually plying the
Atlantic route with the U-boats
lurking in the deep,
so a very risky job.
That was Alf Lennon.
And his mother Julia,
John's mother Julia Lenin,
was a very liberal
woman in her time.
They had married, but
they didn't really ever
have much of a relationship.
There were no photographs of
John Lennon's parents together,
not from their wedding
day or any of the years
they were together.
In fact, they weren't
together very much.
But Julia was unusual in that
she was very attractive to men.
And the fact that
she was married
didn't stop her from
courting other men.
And she had four children
to three different men
in nine years, which sounds
more like today's behavior
if anything, than
1940s behavior.
It obviously marked her out
as very unusual in her time.
But they never
really got the hang
of bringing up
their son together.
And John was kind of passed
from one to the other.
When Alf was back,
John would see his dad.
Otherwise he was with
his mom, but the mom
was mostly going out at night.
So he was really raised by his
auntie, his aunt and uncle,
his aunt Mimi and
his uncle George.
And they gave him the
stability that he needed.
And in 1946, he became the
guardian of his Aunt Mimi
and Uncle George permanently.
MITCH AXELROD: And they
also provided a, I think,
harmonica to him?
MARK LEWISOHN: Yeah John's
mother was very musical.
She played ukulele.
And John's father
played harmonica.
But I don't think John
necessarily knew that.
But he was very good musically.
He had a natural musical talent.
But he also had a great
facility for words.
He was writing really
inventive comic poetry
and doing lots of drawing
from infancy onwards.
MITCH AXELROD: That was
an influence of Mimi
because she had
been an avid reader
and brought that to
influence him in that way.
MARK LEWISOHN: John Lennon was
an avid reader his entire life.
He would read a book or
two a week and a newspaper
or two every day,
cover to cover.
And he did that until
the day he was shot.
So he was always reading.
MITCH AXELROD: And what
about Paula McCartney?
MARK LEWISOHN: Paul
on his mother's side,
there's not so much music there.
She was a midwife.
But on Paul's father's side,
there was a lot of music.
His dad actually had a band.
And much as the Beatles were
playing the Liverpool halls
and club circuit in
the 1960s, so his Dad
had been doing that 40 years
earlier with Jim Mac's Band.
Jim McCartney had
Jim Mac's Band.
He was the leader.
And he played piano and
trumpet and wrote a tune.
So Paul McCartney
was not the first
in his family to write a song.
His dad wrote one before him.
And actually his dad
had been a musician
as well, playing northern
England brass band music, which
I don't think is
so well known here
but very nice kind
of brass music.
TONY TRAGUARDO: Now
Ritchie, I mean,
we know we know him as Ringo,
but throughout the book,
for the most part, he's Ringo
when we talk about him onstage,
but he's Ritchie.
MARK LEWISOHN: Yeah, there's
no hindsight in this book.
So I can't call him Ringo
until he becomes Ringo.
He's about 20 years old by then.
And similarly, I don't use
the word Beatles anywhere
until they actually
come up with the name.
Because until that point,
they're not Beatles.
TONY TRAGUARDO: They're not.
MARK LEWISOHN: So he's
Ritchie, Ritchie Starkey.
TONY TRAGUARDO: Right.
Oh, go ahead.
MARK LEWISOHN: There's a little
bit of music in his background,
but not too much.
But mostly it was
family parties.
Liverpool is a
very musical city.
It's another reason why they
had a rock band scene there.
And that's because Liverpool
is a very musical place.
It's the Irish, the strongly
Irish heritage there.
People, you go to
pubs, you sing.
At a family party, everyone
is expected in turn
to have a turn.
So it would come to
your turn, and you
would have to get up and
read a piece of poetry
or sing or whatever.
And they all had these musical
events in their background.
But Ritchie, the biggest
thing about his childhood
is that he was
seriously ill twice.
On the first occasion,
he was seven years old.
He very nearly died.
Three times his mother was
told he wouldn't last night.
And poor woman, Ritchie
was her only child.
And she would have to go
home on the bus from hospital
thinking she'd
never see him again.
But he was always
a tough little kid.
Not necessarily physically,
but emotionally, mentally, he
is still a very
tough guy, Ringo.
MITCH AXELROD: And didn't
he also at these parties,
after he was sickly
and came home,
he used to sing
"Nobody's Child"?
MARK LEWISOHN: Yeah,
Ritchie liked country music
from America.
And whereas there
is a bit of a myth
that the Beatles always got
their music from the sailors
who sailed between New York
and Liverpool, in reality, they
actually got their records
from shops, as I was saying.
But he, Ritchie, did have a
bit of a supply line there.
And he was into real
American country music,
which all started when he saw
a Gene Autry film at the cinema
when he was 9 or 10.
And living where
he did-- Liverpool
was a very poor city-- but
the area where Ritchie lived
was about the
poorest of them all.
And they had nothing.
And they had no prospects.
And they had no heating.
And they had no hot water.
All these guys had
outside toilets.
Nobody had a toilet inside
the house let alone a bath.
I mean, these things were
completely unheard of.
You would always have to go
into a public bath to wash.
So this was a very
different way of growing up.
And he saw Gene
Autry on the screen
singing "South of the Border."
And he wanted desperately
to go to America
and tried to emigrate
to Houston, Texas
when he was about
19, 20 years old.
TONY TRAGUARDO: Wow.
ROB LEONARD: We didn't
talk about George, yet.
But when we talk about George,
then I have another question.
MARK LEWISOHN: OK.
George doesn't really have
much music in his background.
His dad did get a guitar.
His dad was a sailor, as well.
And he first came to
New York in about 1927.
So both John's father and Paul's
father had been to New York
and, obviously, would talk about
America to a degree at home.
And George's father bought a
guitar actually in New York.
But the times got tough in
the 1930s in the Depression,
and sold it.
But what they had
was American records.
He brought back Roy Rogers
records, "Singing Br Brakeman"
and all that kind of stuff--
Jimmie Rodgers, not Roy Rogers.
I'm sorry.
That is the cowboy, isn't he?
I don't think he made a record.
MITCH AXELROD: No.
ROB LEONARD: Roy
Rogers probably did.
MARK LEWISOHN: Oh, well, maybe.
TONY TRAGUARDO: "Happy Trails."
ROB LEONARD: "Happy Trails."
MARK LEWISOHN: Oh, right.
OK.
So there was music around.
And also there was the
influence of some English music
like George Formby.
I don't know if anybody here has
heard of George Formby, music
hall star in England
who wrote and sang kind
of very saucy songs, risque
double entendre songs.
So they all had music to some
degree or other, Paul the most.
ROB LEONARD: I want to
talk about Brian Epstein.
Here's a guy, he ran a record
shop in his parents' store.
And all of a sudden he
becomes their manager.
And he really sets
a revolution off
by the way he presented the
Beatles and other bands, too.
It wasn't just the Beatles, too.
How important is Brian
Epstein going to the Cavern
in November of 1961?
MARK LEWISOHN: It's vital.
Because the Beatles,
as I said, they
were the hottest
act in Liverpool.
But that was all.
There was no way out.
How do you get out of Liverpool?
How'd you get down to London
and get a recording contract
and become famous?
None of them had any
idea how to do it.
None of the people
in London were
looking up north because
London is always very insular
and people just think that
if it's not happening there,
it's not happening anywhere.
So the music scene as we know
it-- the books I'm writing
have to tell the story of
how the music business, which
was this quaint old thing that
began in Tin Pan Alley in New
York in the 1910s, how that
became the record business,
and how that crossed
the Atlantic.
And ultimately,
through the Beatles,
it became the
music industry with
these vast multimillion--
billion-- dollar companies,
like Google even, that
control all these rights
and find ways of bringing
the music to the marketplace.
This was just a
very little thing
when the Beatles were trying
to get a recording contract.
And it was the
Beatles who actually
made that revolution happen.
So I must show in these
books how the Beatles changed
the music business, how they
changed the entertainment
business.
ROB LEONARD: But Brian
was very sure about that.
Right away, he knew
something was going on.
MARK LEWISOHN: Just as there
was no group like the Beatles--
and believe me, when
the Beatles first
tried to get a
recording contract,
one of the reasons
they struggled
is because no one like that
had ever existed before.
It sounds so simple.
I got drums, bass guitar,
lead guitar, rhythm guitar.
One, two, or three
guys-- or even all four--
who sing, in harmony, and
write their own songs.
God, it's everywhere now.
It was nowhere then.
And it was so nowhere that
no one could recognize
that they were
new and different.
And similarly, Brian
Epstein as manager
was so different to any manager
who had ever been before.
So Brian revolutionized
rock management.
And the Beatles
revolutionized rock music.
And he was a young guy
who was unfulfilled.
He was struggling
to find his way
in life in that he was
very good as a businessman.
He was good enough to be
considered store management
material at the age of 21.
But he was never satisfied
with doing any one thing.
So he would start something
with immense enthusiasm
and after a year he would
get bored and go and do
something else.
He really wanted to be an actor.
He really wanted to
be a dress designer.
direct plays on the stage.
But he couldn't.
Every time he tried one of those
things, it never really worked.
And he ended up dissatisfied
back in Liverpool
until he saw the Beatles.
And he was able to bring to them
all his ideas for presentation
and all his
organization in terms
of management administration.
He was a brilliant
administrator.
One of the joys for
me on this project--
and we talked about how
to get information--
is I was able to find
Brian Einstein's management
files for the Beatles.
And that's all
completely unseen stuff.
And I have a very, very
strong collection of this.
It runs all the way through to
his death in '67 and, in fact,
beyond.
And all that stuff
is completely new.
But what it tells
me is that this guy
was a brilliant organizer.
And the Beatles were always
the best at what they did,
but they had no idea how
to organize themselves.
They needed someone
to come in and shape
the direction for them, to
actually show them the way
to go, and to open up the doors.
And he did it.
TONY TRAGUARDO: Now
the Beatles that we
know that Brian Epstein
took to the topper-most
or the popper-most were John,
Paul, George, and Ringo.
But initially, when
Brian went down
those steps of the Cavern in
Liverpool and saw the band,
there was another drummer there.
I know it's hard to
put into a nutshell,
but sort of the
story of Pete Best.
MARK LEWISOHN: Well,
yeah, the Beatles always
had a problem with
getting a drummer.
In fact, there was a period in
1960 when Paul was a drummer.
So they were a four-piece
with Paul on drums.
But that was always really
frustrating for Paul
because he wanted
to be out front.
So by a miracle of
coincidences, they
end up getting offered this
trip to Hamburg in Germany.
And they must go
as a five-piece.
And it's quite clear that
they need to get one more guy.
And he's going to have to
be a drummer because that
was what they always lacked.
And they knew there was
this kid in Liverpool
with a drum kit and no
particular day-to-day job.
So they grabbed him.
And his name was Pete Best.
And Pete Best was their drummer
until pretty much the eve
of their breakthrough in the UK.
And then he was fired
and then, poor guy,
had to watch while the
Beatles became the biggest
thing that entertainment
had ever known.
I mean, they were hoping to
have a hit record or two.
But they actually kind
of changed the world.
TONY TRAGUARDO: Did a
little bit better than that.
MARK LEWISOHN: Yeah,
and we're still
talking about them
50 years later.
And he's just been having
to watch it for 50 years.
So that was all
quite unfortunate.
TONY TRAGUARDO: But
you do in the book,
though, you do
explain the story.
MARK LEWISOHN: Well, yeah.
TONY TRAGUARDO: How it
all happened and you'll--
MITCH AXELROD: The myth.
TONY TRAGUARDO: You'll
see the myth of--
MARK LEWISOHN: Well, the
Beatles' story is one that
attracts a lot of myths.
It's inevitable
because everyone thinks
they know something of it.
And things get magnified.
And things get told
out of proportion.
One of the things is, why
did they fire Pete Best?
And for some reason,
it's been a mystery
for 50 years as to why
they should fire this guy.
MITCH AXELROD: Even mean to him.
MARK LEWISOHN: So he says.
So he says.
But actually, it's quite
clear when you read the book.
And it isn't me saying it.
It's all the people I talk
to because I have interviewed
hundreds of people who were
witnesses to all these events.
And it's absolutely clear
that he was never really
one of them.
And if you're in a band and
the chemistry isn't right,
then you know it, right?
I mean, you're in a band.
You know these things.
You've got to have
the chemistry right.
And especially if the front
line is so full of personality
and so full of
exuberance and character.
And the guy on the drums
is making no eye contact.
He's a very shy
individual, Pete.
He just looks down, doesn't
make any eye contact,
doesn't smile, doesn't
speak to anyone.
And after the gig, he just
goes home and the other three
hang out together, well,
there's a divide there.
And every time they
played with Ringo,
who was part of
the same scene-- he
was in another
band-- it felt great.
They just immediately
felt this is the guy.
MITCH AXELROD: And Paul,
you said Paul played drums
for a while, but
Paul was actually
the best guitarist
in the Beatles,
wasn't he, for a while?
MARK LEWISOHN: Paul
was pretty good
musically at
anything he picks up.
I mean, he's just
one of those guys who
can pick up any
instrument and that's it.
He's away.
And that can make life
difficult in a band
when ultimately in the
Beatles, he's saying to Ringo,
no, no, no, I could
do-- let me show you.
Because obviously,
you've got to be
aware of the chemistry
of the personalities.
MITCH AXELROD: But he ended
up playing bass guitar.
MARK LEWISOHN: By default.
MITCH AXELROD: Who was
playing bass in Hamburg?
MARK LEWISOHN: Well,
they had another guy
called Stuart Sutcliffe.
The Beatles were originally
a five-piece, not a four.
And Stuart was brilliant,
a brilliant artist--
not so much a brilliant bass
player, but a brilliant artist.
And he gave the Beatles
an image and a look
that was very important
to their development.
And he also
attracted in Germany,
in Hamburg, three bright young
things who were primarily
attracted to Stuart first--
Astrid, Klaus, and Jurgen,
who had a great
influence on the Beatles.
And that's an
interesting story, too,
because they were all war
babies as well, Astrid, Klaus,
and Jurgen.
And they were so disgusted
with their country's behavior
that they grew up after
the war absolutely appalled
to be German because of
what their country had done.
And so they shunned
everything German
and embraced everything French.
So the Beatles went to
Hamburg as young English guys
with Irish background
singing black American music
and got to Hamburg to meet
three people who were totally
influenced by Paris.
And the Beatles became this
melange of all of that.
And when they really
broke America,
they had a continental look, not
an English look and certainly
not an American look.
They were kind of French.
ROB LEONARD: You just talk
about myths from the Beatles.
Your book separated some of the
myths from showing the truth.
What myths bother you
about the Beatles?
MARK LEWISOHN: So many.
I have real difficulty reading
most books on the Beatles,
especially those that
have got an agenda.
The writers often have
an agenda on something.
And they bring that
agenda onto the page.
And they're forcing
their opinions on you.
For me, it's just about
being the narrator.
And I just try and weave other
stories together in this book.
Myths that bother me?
Just too many aspects of their
story are-- they're too pat.
These are very interesting,
challenging, spiky, difficult,
funny, talented,
amusing, original people.
And I just think that you can't
easily put a thought on them
because they were much
more diverse than that.
So I look in this book at the
Beatles from the outside in
and the inside out.
And I want to see their
chemistry with one another
and how they
functioned as a unit.
I mean, how did
these four guys stay
so sane through
such insane times
once they became so
globally popular?
So I look at all that.
But there are so many
elements of the story that
are too easy, like when they
go to India, for example,
and they're with the Maharishi,
which is often just kind
of thrown away as this kind of
silly period in their career
when they just went off to
India and tried to levitate
or whatever.
But in reality,
they're just guys.
They're human
beings who are going
through an extraordinary time.
And they're having to deal with
what fame is bringing them,
fame on an unimagined scale.
No one had ever been
as big as the Beatles.
They are the ever present
loyalty of all celebrity.
To this day, you go in a
room full of celebrities,
Paul McCartney walks in, they
will all turn to look at him.
He's the tops.
And they all were.
The same as true
of John and George.
And it's still true of Ringo.
So they had to deal with this.
So at the ages of
25, 26, 27, 28,
they decided to go and find
out what life was about,
to take that journey.
But being the Beatles, it became
a very, very public thing.
It should have been
a private thing.
But it became very public.
And everyone took the
mickey out of them for it.
And they became kind
of the laughing stock.
But they needed to
find out who they
were to discover themselves.
And when they came
back, they were
different from before they went.
So what happened there in India
is worthy of a proper look.
It's not just to be tossed
away as something silly.
It's like, this is important.
If those guys thought it was
important, it's important.
And at the same time, being the
Beatles, wherever they went,
everyone followed.
This whole business of people
being interested in meditation,
people being interested
in spiritualism
and Eastern
philosophy and so on,
that existed for centuries
before the Beatles,
but they are the great
popularizers of it.
Because they did it, it became a
possibility for everybody else.
MITCH AXELROD: Now
to be fair, 1968
is going to be in Volume Three?
MARK LEWISOHN: Yeah.
MITCH AXELROD: OK,
so we've got to wait.
ROB LEONARD: That's
a while away.
MITCH AXELROD: This only goes
up to the New Year's Eve of '62,
right?
MARK LEWISOHN: This goes up
to the very brink of 1963
when the Beatles have got
a record out in England.
They're already being exposed
to the American market.
They've already
been turned down by,
at the end of this book, three
American record companies.
Because America was no
more prepared to accept
what the Beatles were than
the English market was,
they had to force their way in.
But once people heard
them, that was enough
because the music did the rest.
MITCH AXELROD: Now let's
talk about their idols.
Because we talked about
the music a little bit.
Who were the Beatles idolizing
for American musicians?
MARK LEWISOHN: Elvis,
Elvis, Elvis, Elvis, Elvis.
MITCH AXELROD: Was it Elvis?
MARK LEWISOHN: Absolutely.
It was Elvis.
MITCH AXELROD: I thought so.
MARK LEWISOHN:
Yeah, Elvis Costello
was really big in those days.
Yeah, Elvis and also
very much Buddy Holly
and the Crickets, and very much
Eddie Cochran, and very much
Jerry Lee Lewis, and
very much Carl Perkins.
Little Richard, of
course, Little Richard.
It didn't matter to
them what skin color
the person had
because it was music.
And John Lennon had this
extraordinary experience
when he was 15?
Yes, it was April, 1956.
He had just heard Elvis.
And Elvis was the
greatest thing he had ever
heard in his entire life.
And John Lennon would
always love Elvis
until the day he died.
And then some kids in
his class at school
had been on a school
trip to the Netherlands
and been in a record store there
and bought a Little Richard 78.
Now Little Richard was
not available in the UK
at this point, not until
about eight months later.
And this guy called Michael Hill
had the record with "Long Tall
Sally" on one side and "Slippin'
and Slidin'" on the other,
a 78, and said to John during
the course of a school morning,
I've got a record at
home by a guy who's
probably better than Elvis.
And John who had only heard
of Elvis for about a month,
said, not possible.
Would've told him it
in two short words,
no doubt, what he
thought of that idea.
But at lunch time, they
all bunked out of school,
went and got a bag of chips--
French fries-- back to this guy
Michael's house,
pull on the record,
and John Lennon heard "Long
Tall Sally" for the first time
and was completely stupefied.
And torn, because he
loved Elvis and yet he
loved this guy as well.
And then someone said to
him that Little Richard
was a Negro, as the word was
then-- black, African American.
And it was like, oh, my God.
They make this music, too?
I love it.
And they became
totally passionate
about black American music
from that moment onwards.
MITCH AXELROD: And
to this day, if you
ask Little Richard, he says he
influenced Paul McCartney all
the time, doesn't he?
He'll tell you firsthand, I did.
MARK LEWISOHN: He does.
And they eventually got to
play with Little Richard.
And for them, meeting
Little Richard
was like anybody
else meeting them.
It was like them
and their heroes.
MITCH AXELROD: What
were the first songs
that John and Paul wrote?
MARK LEWISOHN: Well, first of
all, they wrote separately.
And this is one of so many
amazing things in this book.
There were hardly any boys
in the south end of Liverpool
where they were growing up.
Liverpool was a big city.
So it has a north
end and a south end.
It doesn't have a west end
because that's the river.
But it as an east.
And they lived in the
south end of the city.
And John Lennon started writing
songs in 1957 at the age of 16.
His first song was
called "Calypso Rock."
Because as I said,
America believed
that rock and roll was
this five-minute thing.
And we in England, who swallowed
everything that you thought,
thought it would last
five minutes as well.
So it was going to
last five minutes.
And it was preserved
only by the kids.
Because the companies were
already trying to say,
well, here's the next fad.
And the next fad was
going to be calypso music.
So if you read "Billboard" or
"Cashbox" or "Variety" of 1957,
you'll read, calypso
is the coming thing.
Rock and roll is dead.
And that filtered
across to England.
So John Lennon thought, a-ha,
if I'm going to write a song,
I'll try and straddle
the two things.
So he wrote a song
called "Calypso Rock."
And then he wrote a song
called, "Hello, Little Girl."
And Paul, at the
same time, and this
is where it gets
interesting, he was
writing a song called "I Lost My
Little Girl" at the same time.
So before they met, or
around the time they met,
they were both
individually writing songs.
So what are the chances
of two guys-- two kids--
writing songs?
Paul was only 14.
What are the chances of them A,
writing songs, and then finding
each other, and then thinking,
let's write together?
So unusual were the
Beatles in those days
that when Brian
Epstein were trying
to get them a recording
contract in London,
not only were
people telling them
you'll never make it from
Liverpool and go home
and all that kind
of stuff, everyone
said to him you've got to
change the name because the word
Beatles will never catch on.
MITCH AXELROD: Never.
MARK LEWISOHN: Never catch on.
So as weird as that sounds, that
is the thinking back in 1962.
And the Beatles were
always about, stuff you.
We're going to do it our way.
And if you don't like it,
well, we'll just keep it
and you'll pay for it later.
And when they first
went to London,
there's a section
in the book when
they go to London for the first
time to promote themselves
and they go around
meeting journalists,
people were openly
hostile to them.
Your name is horrible,
and you'll never make it,
and all that.
And they, being the Beatles,
they thought, right.
We'll show you.
And they never forgot.
I mean, very tough-minded
guys, the Beatles.
Very tough.
MITCH AXELROD: But they
had a little bit of trouble
with the name in Germany,
too, didn't they?
MARK LEWISOHN: There's
a leading question.
MITCH AXELROD: I had to ask it.
MARK LEWISOHN: In
Germany, the word Beatles
will be pronounced as "peedles."
MITCH AXELROD: Not to end
on a naughty note, but--
MARK LEWISOHN: And
"peedles" actually means
the male appendage in
German in some kind
of slightly schoolboyish talk.
Actually, I quite like the
fact that in America you
always say Beatles with--
MITCH AXELROD: Like a D.
MARK LEWISOHN: Like a D. And
we say Beatles with the T.
But we say Elvis wrong.
Presley.
Because we say
Presley as if it's got
what I would call a
zed and you call a zee.
And you say Presley.
So we name your greatest
star incorrectly.
We pronounce it wrong.
And you pronounce our
greatest star incorrectly.
MITCH AXELROD: Actually, we
don't even say the last name.
We just call him Elvis.
MARK LEWISOHN: The King.
MITCH AXELROD: What's
Madonna's last name?
MARK LEWISOHN: I can't think.
MITCH AXELROD: Just kidding.
MARK LEWISOHN: Cuchione?
MITCH AXELROD: Oh, wow.
ROB LEONARD: Ciccone.
MITCH AXELROD: Someone
Google it right now.
ROB LEONARD: Ciccone.
MITCH AXELROD: There's so much
to talk about in this book.
I mean, it's 1,000 pages.
It really is.
It does go up to '62.
You really need to
buy it and read it.
It's the most incredible
detail you will ever
read on the Beatles.
It really does put
into context who
they were, why they
became who they did,
and, as you say, why they
gelled as ultimately John,
Paul, George, and Ringo.
It was John, Paul,
George, and Pete,
or drummer, or undesirable
member, as you'll read in here.
And then it became Ringo.
MARK LEWISOHN: And that
order is important.
Psychologically,
the constitution
of the Beatles as a band is
John, Paul, George, and Ringo
because John started
it and led them
and he was always the leader.
And he brought in Paul.
And Paul brought in George.
And George brought in Ringo.
So that doesn't just fall
nicely of the tongue,
it's absolutely essential to
understanding the relationships
within the group.
TONY TRAGUARDO: And just to add,
one of the fascinating things
about the book is that it's
written in a narrative form.
And you see sort of how
different people could have--
you know, there were
some near misses
of people who weave in and
out of the Beatles' lives
at different times.
So many instances
of things could
have been radically
different if one domino had
been slightly out of place.
And while other books,
you'd see a little
of that, because you have
it so beautifully laid out,
you really do see the,
if you want to say,
fate or just the circumstances
that put it all together.
Brilliantly done.
MARK LEWISOHN: Thank you.
ROB LEONARD: I also
think you, just
a little review of
the book, you look
at the bigger circle as
well as the inner circle.
I think the people
like Brian Epstein,
you don't start where he
first meets the Beatles.
It's before that.
George Martin and other
people who managed them or--
TONY TRAGUARDO: In the sphere.
ROB LEONARD: In quotes.
MARK LEWISOHN: To
me, it's always wrong
when you get a book
where, for example, Ringo
joins the Beatles in '62.
So most of the
books on the Beatles
will have their
story to that point
and then bring him in and
do a little quick back story
and that's it.
But actually all these people
are growing up in the same city
at the same time.
They're all living there.
They're all on parallel tracks
that sometimes cross over
before they really have met.
This is not a book
about legends.
This is a book about
four people who
thought differently and
acted differently, and were
original and daring and
prepared to break all the rules.
So it's really important to
actually put them properly
all in the same space
at the same time
because they're all going to see
the same films at the same time
in the cinema, the
Elvis films or whatever.
And they're all listening
to the same records.
And they are crossing
over one another
even before they know it.
So it makes it much more
of a cogent and real story
if you've actually got
them in the same place
at the same time.
ROB LEONARD: And also
the fact that they also
met the right people who
believed in them-- Brian
Epstein, George Martin.
If they were signed to Decca--
MARK LEWISOHN: They
were lucky to get
Brian Epstein as their manager.
They were extraordinarily
lucky to get
George Martin as their producer.
And he, in turn,
was extraordinarily
lucky to get them.
Because as I show
in the book, he
didn't actually
want to sign them.
He actually had his arm
twisted to sign them.
But as soon as he met them--
because he signed them
before he met them--
as soon as he met them,
he knew that they were original.
And he worked-- George Martin's
career fell into two paths,
really, which was if he
ever followed a formula
and did whatever the
formulaic thing to do
was with unoriginal talent, the
records were really quite poor.
And I have a
collection of them now,
George Martin's poor records.
There's a box full of them.
But if he ever worked with
original minds, people
who were really creative
in their own right,
he would bring all his
creativity to the palette
as well.
And the results were fantastic.
So meeting the
Beatles, for George,
was just the most perfect thing
because their thing was always,
what do you mean
we can't do that?
It's just like,
what do you mean no?
Well, if you say no, we'll
say yes, as the song goes.
I mean, that actually is Paul
McCartney's mantra to this day.
You say yes, I'll say no.
Or you say no, I'll say yes.
And the Beatles always
operated that way.
As soon as they got
to Abbey Road studios,
and they met a sheet of paper
full of rules like that,
they went, well, we're
going to do that,
and we're going to do that,
and we're going to do that.
And they just broke them all.
And because they
broke them all, they
made "Sergeant Pepper" and
"Revolver" and "Abbey Road"
and "The White Album"
and all these things
that were just culturally
pushing the envelope so far.
MITCH AXELROD: Well,
I want to open it up
to questions from the audience.
But I will say as far as
the narrative in the book,
you do get a sense
when you read this
that you are in their story.
And that's, I think, one
of the biggest compliments
I can pay you.
Because I felt
like I was actually
walking down the street
with John, with George,
with Ringo, and Paul.
And you really were
there with them.
And that has not happened before
in any other book I've read.
So I mean, kudos.
MARK LEWISOHN: Thank you.
MITCH AXELROD: It is a really
fascinating book, really is.
MARK LEWISOHN: Thank you.
TONY TRAGUARDO: To bring
in the ruddles humor,
you brought in the
sights, the sounds,
the smells of the actual.
And you'll read about
that in the book.
There's actually a
comment about the smells.
MITCH AXELROD: So do
we have any questions
from the audience for Mark?
Sure.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for being here.
And thanks for
writing this book.
As one of the only people in the
room who probably saw "The Ed
Sullivan Show" the first
time it was shown--
and my father said that can't
be their real hair-- it became
sort of a genetic piece of
my fabric, of growing up,
my culture and my background.
And I wonder if the
same sort of feeling
happens with any other
artists later on.
Is there another generation
that has another artist that
becomes so genetic
in their core being?
Or is this a once in a
lifetime, once in a generation,
once in a millennium thing?
MARK LEWISOHN: Well, I'll throw
this one open to the panel
here.
But from my own point
of view, I mean,
the obvious answer is that
every generation has its heroes.
And every generation has
its key musical influences.
I always think that
it is the music
you hear when you're,
say, 14 to 19 or 20
that has the greatest
impact on you in terms
of shaping your opinion.
But on the other hand,
subsequent generations
wouldn't have had anything
as profound as the Beatles
or as artistically deep and
satisfying as the Beatles.
Molds can really
only be broken once.
I mean, there are so
many molds to be broken,
but the Beatles just--
they changed so many things
that after that,
everyone was, in a way,
always treading in
their footsteps.
But of course, if asked
an 18-year-old today,
though he might know
of the Beatles, which
is an amazing thing
in itself, that
wouldn't necessarily be
his or her game changer.
That's what I feel.
What do you think?
MITCH AXELROD: Well,
you know, to me,
Dexys Midnight Runners
with "Come On Eileen."
There's no one like
Dexys Midnight Runners.
No, to me, I mean, you're asking
the wrong person because to me,
I'm up here because
of the Beatles.
Well, I'm up here
because of my parents.
But I'm up here, really,
because the Beatles
were a big influence on my life.
I don't think there's
anybody-- you have always said,
there were circumstances that
made the Beatles who they were.
And I don't think
those can happen again.
I just don't.
MARK LEWISOHN: They were
born at the right time.
And they entered our lives
at the right time as well.
ROB LEONARD: I think
some bands have
had a place in rock history.
MARK LEWISOHN: Oh, absolutely.
ROB LEONARD: But I
think culturally,
in the bigger picture,
the Beatles knocked down
so many doors and stuff.
MARK LEWISOHN: I
think, I mean, there
was always this
thing about who's
going to be the next band
to be as big as the Beatles.
And after about 30
years, eventually people
stopped asking because
it just isn't possible.
Times have moved on.
MITCH AXELROD: I think,
actually, the curse--
ROB LEONARD: But there's
no Ed Sullivan show either.
TONY TRAGUARDO: Well, I
was just going to say,
I think part of it has
to do with the idea
that "The Ed Sullivan
Show" was such
a huge simultaneous exposure.
I think that there have
been acts since then.
You read about Elton
John's performance
at the Troubadour that
broke him wide open.
U2 had some stunning
performances.
But these were often
live performances
that were reviewed.
Springsteen being called
the future of rock and roll.
We saw it in
individual performances
that would get reviewed.
But to have had it given to
all of us on the Sullivan show,
here it is.
ROB LEONARD: And
how many bands got
started the next day because
of "The Ed Sullivan Show"?
TONY TRAGUARDO: Because
of "The Ed Sullivan Show."
MITCH AXELROD: Well, it's funny
because I feel bad for Elvis
because Elvis probably
thought the same thing.
Well, no one's going
to be bigger than me.
And then, a few years
later, it's the Beatles.
And, like, oh, damn.
ROB LEONARD: I do have a
question for you, Mark.
And it concerns
the Sullivan show.
Here in America, it's a moment.
In Great Britain,
"The Ed Sullivan Show"
wasn't broadcast there.
How was that looked
at from Great Britain?
MARK LEWISOHN: I used to read
about "The Ed Sullivan Show"
for years as a Beatles fan.
And also I was always interested
in broadcasting, as well.
But I didn't actually see
it until the video age
when you could actually
get to see tapes of things.
For us, that was not the show.
For us, we had our own landmark
moments, a couple of big TV
shows the Beatles did.
But more than anything else,
whereas the Beatles, well,
they were number one at a time
of the Sullivan show here.
But that was where the nation
saw them for the first time.
In England, it happened
a few months earlier.
And it mostly happened
through the records and radio.
And then people saw
them on television
and thought they were great.
We didn't have that
one single defining
moment like you've had here.
MITCH AXELROD: We have our next
question from Mark Lapidos.
We should just tell
everybody that Mark Lapidos
is the founder of what was
known as Beatlefest in 1974
and since changed to The
Fest for Beatles Fans.
And Mark Lewisohn is
going to be a guest,
if you want to tell people
about that after your question.
MARK LAPIDOS: Sure.
First of all, there
are other people here
who were there for
"The Ed Sullivan Show."
And it's a little known
fact that to this day
it's the largest audience in the
history of American television
by population size.
So the population was like 160.
So it's like, I think,
42%, something like that.
And Superbowl never gets
more than 33%, I don't think.
So that Ed Sullivan show,
as George said, of course,
many times, even the
criminals, they don't watch us.
But anyway, I have a question.
I have no idea if you're
writing about this
because this book only
goes up to the end of '62
and I'm only up
to page 50 or 60.
It's going to take me maybe
10 years to get through it.
But I'm loving it so far.
I don't know how much you delve
into the music part of it.
But I guess for book three, I
have a bit of Beatles trivia
I'd like to ask you about.
I asked George Martin,
and he answered it.
But I want to know if
you know about this,
what your answer would be.
"Penny Lane."
I met with him
about 20 years ago.
I said, can I ask you
one trivia question?
He said, sure.
I said, what happened at
the end of "Penny Lane"?
Why is it only on the
promotional single in the US?
So do you have an answer, Mark?
MARK LEWISOHN: Why--
TONY TRAGUARDO: You
should let people what--
MITCH AXELROD: You mean
the trumpet ending.
MARK LAPIDOS: The trumpets,
the trumpet ending,
it's only on the
promotional single.
It never made it on the
American single or album.
MARK LEWISOHN:
Did he tell you it
was because Paul wanted to
change it at the last minute?
MARK LAPIDOS: No.
MARK LEWISOHN: What
did he tell you?
MARK LAPIDOS: I'll give you
an answer in a minute, but--
TONY TRAGUARDO: Well, now
we know what the answer is.
We already know the answer.
MARK LAPIDOS: This is
exactly what he said.
He said, we were
just making music.
We just sent it over.
He didn't even know it.
He was like, all right.
We'll send it over.
Oh, it's not finished?
Doesn't matter, just do it.
Never gave it a thought.
It surprised the hell out of me.
MARK LEWISOHN: They were
turning out product.
I mean, that is yet
another amazing thing
about the Beatles is that all
the recorded material that we
know and love all came out
in the space of about 7
and 1/2 years.
I mean, 13 albums
in 7 and 1/2 years,
if you're looking at
the UK products, which
is the way they shaped it.
And all those singles and
other tracks, as well.
I mean, 200-odd
tracks in seven years.
An act these days
would probably do
one or two albums in that time?
And they completely wiped
clean and drew again
the face of popular
music in that period.
One of the things
I do in this book
is actually name
number all the years.
So 1958 is really the year when
the Beatles are first-- they're
not the Beatles yet,
but in fact, they
went around as a
trio at one point--
John, Paul, and George--
called J Page 3.
TONY TRAGUARDO: That
was a new discovery.
That was something that
had never surfaced before.
Where did you find--
MARK LEWISOHN: Tracked down
this guy who was actually
their manager for a while
and had a recording of them
that he wiped, unfortunately.
But they were J Page 3.
J for John, P-A for
Paul, and G-E for George,
and 3 because they were
a trio, three guitarists.
And that is year one.
1958, when they started going
around together, is year one.
So 1964, when they
played the Sullivan show,
that's year seven.
There's a tendency
in America to think
they kind of arrived when
they played the Sullivan show,
but that was year seven.
And when they broke
up, it was year 13.
Now they don't get a recording
contract until year five,
but that doesn't mean
they're not together.
They're still very much working
and finding out who they are,
and young lads having
fun and all that,
and having adventures.
Actually, they were
together 13 years,
much more than people realize.
MITCH AXELROD: And
we did want to say
that Mark will be at The
Fest for Beatles fans
on this Sunday,
February 9, correct?
MARK LEWISOHN: The anniversary
of the Sullivan show.
MITCH AXELROD: Absolutely.
MARK LEWISOHN: I shall
being doing my Ed Sullivan
impressions.
MITCH AXELROD: Oh, good.
I'll be doing my Topo
Gigio impression.
I'm short enough so.
Do we have any other
questions for Mark?
TONY TRAGUARDO: We're
being told to wrap it up.
MITCH AXELROD: We're
One more question?
Anybody?
Al?
AUDIENCE: Actually,
I did have one--
MITCH AXELROD: Can you
go to the mic, please?
AUDIENCE: OK.
MITCH AXELROD: Sorry.
And then I believe Mark
will be doing signing.
We don't?
I'm sorry, Al, you--
TONY TRAGUARDO: Can you
ask it in private, Al?
MITCH AXELROD: Yeah,
ask it in private, Al.
Sorry.
We'll ask it after.
AUDIENCE: OK, real quick.
MITCH AXELROD: Oh, I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: Mark, you
talked about the hostility
that the London music
establishment had
toward Liverpool, or
indifference, maybe.
And yet there was in that
first batch of teen idols,
there was one
Liverpudlian, Billy Fury.
But he didn't apparently
become sort of an icon
for the other budding
musicians in Liverpool.
Is there a particular
reason for that?
MARK LEWISOHN: Yeah, Billy
Fury was the first Liverpool
rock-and-roll star
before the Beatles.
His real name was
Ronald Wycherly.
And he actually was in the
same class at school as Ringo.
But so embarrassing was
the Liverpool accent,
or perceived to be in
those days in the UK--
and that's another
thing the Beatles did.
In my country, in
England, they completely
changed the class system.
Well, not changed it,
but challenged it.
And opened it up to people.
Because they had northern
working class accents.
And that had always been
embarrassing before.
Billy Fury never
said a word publicly
because of his Liverpool accent.
His manager said to
him, don't speak.
And when he sang, he sang
in an American voice.
So no one really knew
he was from Liverpool.
It wasn't important.
But when the Beatles broke
through, it's like, yeah,
we're from Liverpool.
We're from the north.
You got a problem with that?
And that was a real
challenge to people,
which is why they received
hostility to begin with.
But eventually,
within about a year,
everyone was putting on a
northern accent to be cool.
That's just a small measure
of the impact that they had.
MITCH AXELROD: Well, the
book is called "The Beatles
All These Years,
Tune In, Volume One."
There will be three of
these by Crown Archetype.
Thank you very much.
We appreciate Mark being here.
We appreciate Google
having us here.
[APPLAUSE]
MARK LEWISOHN: Thank you.
MITCH AXELROD: Thank you.